Today we are trying out this table setup
With us here we have got Benedek Olah
9-time Finnish Champion
We are going to take on Otto and Emil in a game of doubles
Come on!
That's good!
Backhand through the wall!
I really wanted to hit!
Come on Emil! You can beat him!
What a shot!
I never expected that
Touch! It touched!
It touched!
I get it
Is it all you got?
I got it!
He was so hungry for the around the net!
I trusted you!
This is your side!
Come on!
I was standing here like:
Please don't go on!
Nice Emil
Drop shot!
How did we win that point?
Full power!
Here we go again
You got it
Otto is running!
Come on!
I can't believe that!
That was sick!
Thanks for watching guys
Remember to hit subscribe
And check out our previous videos
Until next time!